[Music]
please
[Music]
here is uh where you can go if you want
help on any topics that you will see
today in this game um
here you can take a screenshot or
something or come back to it
all right are we ready are we ready now
don't
okay let's go
okay for a second i thought we had no
audio
hello
she's got some gnarly ass scars going on
foreign
[Music]
is
horror stories as bad stories
okay
everybody
oh
foreign
the old tree growing on the something
esperanza
where to speak up
hi mate keep listening
and that's almost gonna be like one evil
man
why
jealousy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she
[Music]
why don't you come in because the man
killed hair
[Music]
okay but she wasn't killed
by the man she loved she was killed by a
different man
for three years with a nanny but when i
came home i quickly
[Music]
[Music]
i was trying to photograph animals or
whatever was in that damn
[Music]
lane you for the follow
who is that
koyabi
to interact okay
oh these are my cameras
[Music]
you
[Music]
teach me a new language and teach me how
to use old cameras
the camera kinah
imagine
is it gonna be the lady am i gonna get a
jump scare i don't want it
[Music]
i feel like my
mouth is not sensitive at all but i
don't know it's supposed to be like that
oh
[Music]
you
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sadly
uh
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
i dragged the lifeless body as best i
could to the shore trying not to drown
myself
only when i lifted her in my arms that i
realized who she was
it was my sister
my twin a part of me
dad
[Music]
well yeah
your twin in your dress as well why is
she
okay
foreign
foreign
[Music]
who's shouting that
[Music]
[Music]
and the pain became bearable i felt
protected
mother are you okay she asked me
speaking slowly in order to let me read
her lips
oh
crap she thought she was a twin sister
oh my god so she just pretended to be a
sister
i didn't realize i'd done something that
couldn't be in there
i would have to pretend to be martha
forever oh that's bad and martha saw her
sister's death
crap
that's dark
because my mom didn't love her why
i guess that's why she was only happy
with her nanny
oh this is an interesting uh concept
sorry i need to get the right okay here
we go
um
foreign
[Music]
can i play the piano
[Music]
what's this
what's this love
[Music]
oh this is the lighter
okay it's like these candles
[Music]
so at least her dad loved her then i
wonder why amanda
it's very strange
the music is creepy
silly
[Music]
oh i gotta collect the flowers before
she gets angry okay i'm coming
this way
[Music]
my beard is blonde
[Music]
do you see many blond bears still
[Music]
um
why why have they locked her up she's
supposed to be the the loved child
no
[Music]
oh jesus christ why was that so loud
d
oh
and she's still alive
[Music]
hmm
all she cared about was that my death
was so painful for martha
[Music]
who died and it was better for me too
that people thought that because
but the guilt began to consume me
because that's when i started having
horrible nightmares
martha
oh has
lost
her
soul
so
my
foreign
[Music]
it was wrong it was wrong brain name is
wrong i
go get
no
it's obviously gonna be the bad ones
isn't it i
stole her soul from her
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
identity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell
ah
really i have to keep going
[Music]
you don't need her face
you already look alike
it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i am so sorry
[Music]
why
i did not need to oh god why
i don't
oh
that actually gave me chills
that was disgusting
we are now leatherface
what
what
oh my gosh
oh
please no we're not gonna take a picture
of her dead are we don't i mean that
used to be a thing though to be fair
they did used to do that
i mean the top two aren't too bad but
the bottom one is definitely scary
good morning
such a bright day today unless i just
woke up really late
okay let's go try and find a key then
oh i get to choose
should we wear martha's clothes or
should we wear our clothes
where's that music come from hello
someone outside singing
possible love interest but of me and i'm
dead because i'm martha now
duh this is getting too awkward
okay let's put on these clothes i feel
like it's
the game is kind of wanting me to do
this so let's play properly unless we're
black though because we're just
oh
so we're in morning
fine i guess we'll just wear white
because i don't want to wear polka dots
i just me know like you
i got a a an achievement for being a
magician i don't know why though
but i am a magician apparently
myself
[Music]
we moved here today and i forgot my
album
that's okay
what's happening
okay
[Music]
the white lady that played
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
all sounds pretty normal to me
[Music]
i mean
[Music]
did i miss here when i heard at the
beginning that i was supposed to be deaf
like me is in math
martha
because she keeps saying she's going to
call me and stuff
oh there you go
be careful
okay okay okay good because i was just
wondering
all right
e to her trinket box but i guess maybe
we'll find that later
[Music]
this reminds me of my auntie's house uh
my auntie
uh and uncle they had a farm in like
literally the middle of nowhere and
their house was quite like this it was
very nice and there was apple orchards
outside and
oh we used to we used to make like a a
slide uh with um washing up liquid and
we would put like loads of mats down so
you go
you just like
come right down the end of the garden it
was it was so much fun um and they used
to have like chickens
does not smell often
but then the chickens kept getting eaten
by the foxes
so they had to stop getting their
chickens
is that her
mom and dad's room
okay
okay
i'm coming
in
foreign
ah
yep
the newspaper martha always reads the
newspaper i have to do the same as her
so no one will get suspicious okay
i like to always have my camera with me
when you least expect it the opportunity
father left on the table okay
[Music]
photography
foreign
so much to look at
oh my gosh this place is gorgeous
hello
aha here's where i put it
hello a little star
how do i take a picture of you
aha
julia's camera it's 1940
with rolly called with 120 millimeter
film
you used to take photos throughout the
game some photos will have hidden
elements that will progress the game
story interesting
while holding the camera an icon will
appear to indicate points of
photographic interest
the icon will appear and become clearer
the closer you are okay
press e to see your camera and any
fitted attachments
oh i can get skins
okay
look for the subject you want to
photograph and press to continue or
queue to exit camera mode
i want this one
okay
we don't have any extras do we no
okay
all right so you're in focus oh
a bit squiffy
ah no
down please
you know what script
perfectionist can you tell i'm a
perfectionist
remember to focus i did ab i did i did
it sounds complicated but it's pretty
simple
there was a lot there usually in games
like that it's like press this to shoot
press this to zoom and that's like
basically it
congratulations you've taken your very
first photo
you can shoot as many photos as you want
throughout the game but remember that
only a few will be critical to the
story's progress soon you'll learn how
to survive the photos you've taken okay
try taking a photo of the sparrow
outside i already did this
okay
foreign
surely a dark room would be down here
is that blood
oh is it wine
okay
looks a bit ominous but uh oh there it
is
okay well i haven't got a weapon
but sure i'll take it i don't know why i
need those
my
yeah julia is but not
is that the name julia
i feel like i always get it wrong but
not uh martha because well i guess
martha's probably allowed but she just
never does it so i guess she can't be
found in here or they'll know that
you're not her
photographer used to be so
complicated
and now it's so simple
i just snap a picture and i just shove
it into lightroom and put a preset on it
turn some knobs
[Music]
okay uh where's my birdie
[Music]
okay there are lines
when the red filter is removed the image
is exposed onto the paper
this process has been automatically
faster than what happens in real life
well yeah
i would hope so
[Music]
but i appreciate they're trying to teach
us the true science behind it
immerse the paper in the developer and
the image will appear
to achieve the ideal exposure to the
paper out of the developer when the
timer is green okay i took the paper out
too early today the picture will be
ruined you have to print it again
loser
okay
[Music]
yes thank you
[Music]
oh am i going to take one on the chair
with the the light beam coming down
the art of filmmaking
it depicts the horror of old photography
oh shut up shut up
oh cheers
[Music]
okay so now i guess we're gonna
put the camera there
yes
it's actually
i well no the whole ripping the face off
i mean that was scary but since then
it's been a pretty chill game i think
pretty chill
all right let's let's uh sit in this
beautiful little way of sun
is she gonna do one of her weird faces
like she said she does
sulky smiling nature
hey
please
no i should have been sulky can i do it
again i want to do it again
i'm not going to do neutral though
i want to do it again can i do it again
i want another i went to round two
i have to go
i want salty
[Music]
yeah
yeah
let's get you in the center of the paper
please
um
yeah
yeah that's good
uh
adjust the focus
there
yeah
oh
i have to press this space
you can see it coming together
okay no creepy ghosts
[Music]
well of course you know who you are
the soul in the photo
the memory of that day at the lake was
becoming more and more like a dream
after awakening the image becomes more
amazing
could it be
i kept hoping they would confirm my
feeling memory
okay so because she had the cameras set
oh jesus
no this is bad idea don't do it don't do
it don't do it
[Music]
okay it's good to know
something in my diary
oh
confused
[Music]
[Music]
person
okay the music is now scary
it's gone spooky i'm glad i have these
scissors though
uh okay
let's tell you what
we need to go to daddy's
study
where is his study
she's still here oh that's oh yeah she
wanted to take a picture of her
well
when the moment arrives
okay
okay why why do i keep putting that away
can can i just have it out all the time
please
even if i am gonna look at phones and
say no i don't want to use it mate
um
right so we need to
find the room below
dad's bedroom
oh what's this
[Music]
oh i got a new skin
uh
would it be down here
in the studio is that his office nah it
can't be surely
oh this place is creepy
a okay so now i can take photos in the
dark
what's this
filters
what's that
yeah
it's got to be upstairs then
oh
i spun around way too quick there
oh well i that was not open before
i don't want to use the phone
hello
oh here it is perfect exactly what i
needed
cool
and she got the light out
defensive line
there's the key as well
i'm worried about triggers
so like i don't want the next part of
the game to be triggered oh this is a
nice place to paint
yes i like this
little easel up by a nice little view so
it's very foggy out today though
uh i'm guessing i can take the key and
it won't trigger anything
no good
you just allow me to progress which is
nice
please
thank you
i'm gonna take a photo of my dead sister
that is
kind of me that everyone thinks is me
but i am me
but i'm pretending to be my sister
oh hi
oh no i can't i can it's disgusting i'm
sorry
i shouldn't take take the nick out of
this
right
it's still too dark
too dark
properly exposed hell yeah
not that focused again
there we go okay
i really thought she was going to wake
up
didn't like that didn't like that at all
i definitely wasn't the only one who
thought she was gonna wake up either you
thought she was right
you definitely thought she was
um
we might as well while we're here take
that other photo of like the barrels
because for some reason it allows us to
do that
don't know why i press that button
um
required add-ons okay so let's use these
add-ons
uh heads-up i
am
oh no that one
probably gonna finish the stream
in the next like 15 minutes-ish
something like that
too dark
okay
okay
cool picture
oh [ __ ] now what the hell just
happened
okay
i don't like it
i don't know just something about taking
pictures in the dark just puts me on
edge
i don't like it
and the fact has been pretty chill for a
long time now and i know it's a horror
game also puts me on edge so i'm just
like doubly put on edge right now
uh okay
which photo should we do first should we
do the barrel so let's do the barrels
let's do a good barrel
and then we'll do our system because
that's the main one isn't it really
ah okay so let's do barrels
what a beautiful picture of some barrels
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
let's skip this bit apparently
whoa wait there's writing
what does it say
he says something he who flees from the
light hides behind it
[Music]
weird
interesting okay so i'm glad we did that
the good old barrels
canaries valet on the good older barrels
okay develop this
[Music]
okay
something like this oh such a
it's such a spooky picture i don't like
it
i don't like it
i'm too much of a perfectionist for this
game
[Music]
sure something like that i don't want to
cut off the tops of the chairs
[Music]
is there gonna be something on here
but it's gotta be surely
[Music]
no
it's
[Music]
i cut off the tops of the chair
no
okay
fine
[Music]
well
part of me thinks it's a really good
time to end it here
but maybe maybe we'll just leave the
house and see what's what's about
but we will have to leave
or finish the stream soon
[Music]
okay
we have the key
we'll get the guy
interesting facts
do you want to close the door behind you
because you know you're letting the
draft and that's not good for anyone
ah that's good
handy dandy much better than a bloody
lighter
hey there
so which way to the river then
[Music]
i've done a lot of things wrong and i
swear
[Music]
m
[Music]
this way
ah
i can only surmise i'm going in the
right direction
i think i might now be going in the
wrong direction
maybe we go down
it seems so open world doesn't it
hello
trees
okay
oh my god
[Music]
don't hurt me i'm going to take a
picture of the stick
excuse me
excuse me
did you hear that
i'm very confused please don't kill me
or anything because if you do i'm gonna
stop playing the game
uh
wait is it q and e it's such weird
controls i can't get used to it um okay
[Music]
oh sure
wait what's my uh can i use a lens
artificial macro orange filter
oh let's do this one see how that turns
out
um cool
without you
uh
why is there a cross here
if you could ever
[Music]
[Music]
so i could put living
[Music]
i i feel like i went the wrong way but
there is a house here
if you shoot outside
okay i found a house
everybody i found a house now what
turn around oh jesus i think i did go
the wrong way
sorry i need to stop singing it's what i
do it's like a reflex
why is there a bloody grave here it's
confusing and scary and weird and i
can't even she doesn't even comment on
it which is the even weirder thing and i
can't
it doesn't allow me to take photo or
well it might be but
it's not telling me to
seems like quite a significant thing to
me though
but then maybe i was supposed to carry
on down here so i'll carry on down here
[Music]
oh
what is this a shrine
is it lit for her
or is it just
lit to lit a pathway
i don't know let's carry on
hello
[Music]
can you show me where the whimmer is the
weather the weather
please
are you behind me
oh shut
shut up
what the [ __ ] stop it's not even scary
stop
like getting into myself
[Music]
i don't like it stop saying weird stuff
in my head
do you hear that the weird like
photography
okay let's go get these these pickies
that's what we started with
yeah
[Music]
speedboat hell yeah
oh this is this is you know what place
this is
where we ripped off her face
not nice
okay
how do we get
okay we gotta get back
mhm
do you not hear the sounds in there it's
like more like it's really
do you know it's not now i'll call them
out when i hear them again
i'll try and be quiet so you can hear
them
instead of shouting at them
[Music]
another one
[Music]
okay
so
oh macro let's use a macro oh yeah baby
yeah macro
subject framed too bright okay let's put
the exposure right down
um
about so if we have the aperture low
that allows for a better depth of field
i don't know if that's correct but
that's what i'm thinking
[Music]
okay so where is the third one then
because we found a random house
uh
and we found a grave but we didn't find
any
camera there so i feel like we might
have
walked past one
or something
missed it somewhere
let's go back up see if there's another
way
[Music]
oh there is this way
[Music]
i keep expecting her to kind of jump out
from behind a tree
oh
[Music]
did you hear
i was quiet
what
oh is that the way home off a fox sick
didn't know that
all right
i did miss a camera
where
yeah it's going crazy what did you not
hear me
did you not hear it
one you be next to the pier oh what ah
bull okay
buffer just not seeing it down there
sorry about this
just gonna go back down here
don't hurt me
i thought so because there's a light
here and it seems to be lights by all
the cameras but they're
i can't see a camera here am i stupid
ah it's on there
hello
yes please let's get the bloody hell out
of it
whoa whoa frame rate what's happening
okay
this way
i'm definitely gonna have to play around
with these controls i'm really sorry if
this has been a bad quality
uh video
i'll try and see what i can do for next
week
make it look a bit nicer why is the the
light is not light enough
oh it must be coming out
going out
coming out no going out lights don't
come out they go out
oh gosh i can hardly see
no thank you i don't want it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay
we got
like this game like every game was quick
to my best ever where the [ __ ] am i
going this one
julia
oh no
it's really tight and
i don't like it i think i went the wrong
way it's very hairy
oh gosh
what the hell
where am i
uh what the frick
okay
uh
knock knock satan is that you
it is i
julia
[Music]
oh this is not quite what i thought hell
would look like but i'm glad to be home
thank you
okay the door's closed
why am i tiny
have they made me sure oh i'm a kid am i
a kid again
i'm i'm a kid again
i think i'm a kid
what
[Music]
oh it's just strings
wow that looks really good though
[Music]
wait
no
no
[Music]
why
oh god
am i the baby
am i the baby in her stomach
what viewpoint is this
oh god
[Music]
wait oh am i moving can i move no i
can't
i thought i was going to swim through
the water
that was so weird what the hell just
happened
that was so strange i don't understand
no way i was like what
me too same
what
do you know
[Music]
well you have been through enough to
make you crazy though
are you on your period
unless she had
no doubt
i mean the only thing i'm thinking
a miscarriage but
what
how
what i mean she was seeing that guy i
guess but no that's that's too morbid
that's so so morbid um
look it's the picture that we took why
is it upside down
i guess to depict that it's
hard pretending to be someone else
okay well that was weird and morbid and
i think that's where we're going to
leave it today
so um
i will look once more oh i can save here
that's good
oh there's auto saves anyway so
i guess we'll just
auto save here
um
yeah say please
yeah so that was um
interesting it was a lot like slower
than i thought which is not that's not a
bad thing especially in a horror game
it's it's sometimes actually really nice
to have a
build up you know what i mean it's not
just like jump scare jumps guys jump
scare um the story is definitely not
what i had expected i thought it was
just going to be like a
kind of generic
this person has died and now they're
they're haunting me or something but the
whole her trying to be or pretending to
be her deaf sister
uh that's
that's a lot that is a lot so i can
completely understand why she
could possibly be going crazy
uh and the whole lady of the lake thing
i i love that horror story i know it's
been done quite a few times i mean it
was like
king arthur a lady of the late gave him
the the
sword and then it was in like fly mana
which was i think that's was based on a
series of books and stuff but
always super freaking creepy concept i
love it
um
but yeah it should be good i'm looking
forward to carrying on i just hope that
i can figure out how to do the frame how
to make the frame rate a bit better i
did see i think uh you rick's like said
that it was a bug in the game
so very sorry about that fingers crossed
there will be like an update in the game
that makes uh it makes it run a bit
better i'll have a look and see if i can
update any of my uh graphics
cards um
maybe that will help but yeah we'll see
what we can do for next week either way
i hope you enjoyed hope you liked it
thank you very much for joining i will
see you
uh
next thursday 8 30 p.m gmt
right here on twitch okay
see you then